في حملة مباشرة ،
وعد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
بتوسيع حدود إسرائيل إذا
فاز في إعادة انتخابه الأسبوع المقبل ، أعلن
عن خطة مذهلة لضم أجزاء من
الأراضي المتنازع عليها في الضفة الغربية.
Kavinoky اليوم أعلن عزمي
على تطبيق
السيادة الإسرائيلية على غور الأردن
وشمال البحر الميت ، إنها خطة شاملة
ويقول النقاد إن اللوحة كانت قاعدة
تأتي مع شروط مرفقة بالقانون
يقال ، لن أفعل أي شيء دون
الحصول على تصريح واضح  تفويض من الجمهور
، ولذلك طلبت من مواطني إسرائيل
تفويضًا واضحًا للقيام بذلك ،
فقد قدم الزعيم الإسرائيلي البالغ من العمر 69 عامًا
وعودًا بالضم من قبل ولكن لم
يعجبه أبدًا سحب خريطة أظهر
مناطق معينة في الضفة الغربية.
جعل الأراضي الإسرائيلية الرسمية مناطق
يقول إنها ضرورية للأمن القومي
لكنها محتلة من قبل
معظم المجتمع الدولي